bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur st france le liban qui passe
donc la barre des 100000 contamination
et va donc se dé confiné partiellement
est-ce que c'est prématuré le liban est
partagé d'un côté de 7 à cette urgence
sanitaire
cette catastrophe est cette cascade de
complications avec l'évolution du coc
vide et d'un autre côté la situation
économique très précaire car le liban
vis depuis quelques mois une situation
économique des plus mauvaises de son
histoire
donc il faut faire un juste milieu
c'est pour cela que le gouvernement a
tenté un déconfinement partielle des
prudents cela étant les deux semaines de
confinement vont pas porter le résultat
les résultats du mois attendue car le
taux de positivité
quoique stable reste très élevé à 15 %
c'est pour cela qu'on se pose des
questions sur la prématurité de ceux des
confinement pour quelles raisons
docteur ces mesures ont été un échec au
niveau comment vous vous l'expliquer
d'un côté les deux semaines je pense ne
sont pas suffisants pour porter à un
fruit leurs fruits concrets
d'un autre côté le confinement n'a pas
été respecté dans toutes les régions du
liban de façon homogène il ya des lits
et de tous côtés
donc les régions audi bande le profil
m'en étais un peu hétérogène
c'est à dire peut-être de mauvaises
décisions de la part des autorités il
aurait fallu peut-être faire autrement
selon vous c'est à dire que les
autorités libanaises ont fait un grand
pas dans l'amélioration du dans le
renforcement du système sanitaire autant
que possible car les moyens sont limités
les deux semaines ont permis aux
hôpitaux et au secteur médical de
souffler un peu
le secteur médical était saturé encore
nous avons près de 91 85 et 90 % des
lits de soins intensifs qui sont encore
occupés 70 % des 10
l'hospitalisation régulation encore
occupés on savait que les coller les
patients du coc vite ne sont pas ne
peuvent pas être guéri rapidement il
faut un séjour hospitalier d'arras et
prolonger les moyens du pays sont
limitées des moyens financiers du
ministère de la santé des autres
ministères sont limitées car la crise
économique sévit depuis des mois et
depuis presqu'un sommes nous prêts que
nous allons du au liban d'une
catastrophe à l'autre depuis l'arrivée
puis l'arrêt de l'exécutif puis
maintenant l'absence de gouvernement
sans parler sans oublier de parler de
l'événement majeur du 4-août l'explosion
du 4 août qui était un désastre pour
tout le secteur notamment le secteur de
santé qui a perdu pendant des mois près
de 50% de sa capacité notamment à
beyrouth
donc les moyens de lutter contre la
maladie sont concrètement difficile
d'un autre côté le corps médical lui
même est touché gravement pas cette
passe est évident et assez par cette
épidémie nombre de nombre de nos
collègues sont malheureusement décédés
d'autres sont confinés autant les
infirmières que les médecins sont
touchés par cette par cette épidémie
graf
aujourd'hui évidemment les lueurs
d'espoir vont vers le vexin partout dans
le monde notamment en europe on en parle
beaucoup est ce que c'est le cas au
liban
sur ce plan quelle est la stratégie
adoptée par le gouvernement
évidemment nous attendons comme tous les
pays du monde les vaccins leur
efficacité leur disponibilité j'espère
que ce serait pas ça va pas tarder
longtemps pour l'instant nous voulons
insister et hélas nous devons insister
sur la nécessité de respecter les
consignes médicales autant par tous les
citoyens que par les professionnels car
le meilleur moyen mais non que nous
avons c'est la prévention la prévention
les mesures sanitaires la distanciation
le port des masques d'aération sondés
sont des impératifs c'est à most
actuellement car c'est notre seul moyen
de prévenir la maladie
une fois il faut attendre qu vite après
on sait pas l'évolution c'est vrai qu'il
ya des critères de dévolution mais
l'évolution peut être imprévisible
merci nagy abi rached médecin
cardiologue au liban d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous exposer cette situation
est également compliquée au liban du
côté de la crise sanitaire merci à vous